the penny once again on the cover of
this month's infant swallow Vols
magazine the US Mint produces around 8
billion new pennies every single year
which is strange considering pennies are
currently worth so little they're not
even worth what they're worth according
to the government each new penny now
costs roughly 1.7 cents to make
rendering each a loss from the start
it's true 1.7 cents to make one cent
that really makes the phrase you have to
spend money to make money ring painfully
true so so we spend around 136 million
dollars a year making 80 million dollars
worth of currency that let's face it no
one really uses one study found that
two-thirds of pennies don't circulate
and yet the penny hangs around for no
reason like the appendix or the new
Muppet TV show how is this still on and
how did someone somewhere think you know
what the problem with them up it is
Kermit doesn't enough pigs let's
have a different pig let's do that let's
let's all do that in fact a few years
back a local station in New York sent
out a camera crew to put the penny to
the test
I performed a little experiment down the
street today dumped 150 pennies onto the
sidewalk and just watched who would pick
them up people saw the pennies like this
woman but kept walking after 25 minutes
not one person bent down think about
that a penny is actual US currency and
yet the prospect of a free one on the
ground is treated like a free copy of
Kirstie Alley's memoir resting in a used
diaper and if you thinking well come on
John that's just one instance no it's
not a few years later a San Francisco
news crew ran the exact same experiment
it's your lucky day
Abe Lincoln face up on the sidewalk
better move quick he'll be gone any
second right you don't want them no
strolling pennies on the ground is
essentially catnip to local news crews
hey did an old woman celebrate a
birthday no ok did an animal do
something funny no ok get me a handful
of pennies and a camera I'm getting us
to the 10:30 repeater friends who wants
a penny but our indifference to pennies
doesn't stop there in a 2002 Gallup poll
two percent of Americans admitted to
regularly throwing pennies in the
garbage which means the US Mint is
spending millions to make garbage and
that's not their job that's M night
Shyamalan job and what I love and when
we're not throwing pennies in the
garbage we're doing even worse things
with them as attested to by a reddit
thread titled I put a penny in my butt
and now I can't get it out and before
you ask apparently the reason they did
it was and I quote I wanted to know what
it would feel like to put a cold penny
up my butt I put it in the fridge for
like two to three hours first a little
known fact that's actually how Daniel
day-lewis prepared to buy Abraham
Lincoln and incidentally and this is
also true that penny is currently in
your pocket and it's not just hard to
carry pennies around it can be hard to
spend them according to the Treasury
Department private businesses are free
to prohibit payment in pennies and some
of them have caught on to this at a
growing number of businesses including
Mike's Bikes in San Rafael pennies have
fallen from favor now it Mike's
every cash transaction rounds down to
the nearest nickel pin a customer's
favor their reaction has been
overwhelmingly under whelming whatever
is easier I don't care
oh I'm pretty sure we just found the man
who gives the least amount of shits in
American history someone out there needs
to mean with this beautiful man and do
it now
in fact in fact as far as I can tell
there are only two things pennies are
genuinely good for one you can throw a
penny in a fountain to make a wish
but at its current value no fountain is
granting your wish
unless it's incredibly small like I wish
somewhere in the world a mouse has a
good day
or I wish I knew what a penny looked
like under water the only other option
is use pennies out of pure spite like
this unc charlotte student did with a
parking fine coil went to three
different banks to get five twenty five
dollar boxes containing 2,500 pennies
that got him to reach his total of
eleven thousand and i brought him in
three separate buckets for them he sat
there while two workers counted every
single penny i took them approximately
three hundred and forty minutes Wow
that college kid sure taught those two
employees who had nothing to do with the
policy he was protesting a lesson I bet
the school gave him his own parking spot
after that and it is worth noting
pennies don't just waste our time having
them hanging around can sometimes be
downright dangerous jack is a voracious
eater says his owner Tim Kelleher this
is how it happens he jumped up on the
desk trying to get something man and he
chewed through the bag and he knocked
the box over and pennies were everywhere
and he licked up the pennies and he
lifts up 111 of them oh
a hundred and eleven pennies at that
point that dog had more Lincoln in him
than Mary Todd
and by the way and this is also true one
of the pennies inside that dog is in
your pocket right now so why haven't we
gotten rid of the penny well one reason
believe it or not is that there is a
penny lobby and at the forefront is a
terribly named group called Americans
for common sense who spokesman has some
pretty unconvincing arguments Americans
overwhelmingly want to keep the penny
and no one has explained how we would
replace the millions of dollars that are
raised by charities and charity drives
every year if we didn't have the penny
around wait so his argument is no one
would give to charity if they couldn't
give something basically worthless which
is a pretty cynical view of humanity
I'll be honest I don't think much of
people but even I have to believe they'd
be willing to break out a nickel and you
might want to take his argument with a
grain of salt
given his group's backers Willers a
lobbyist for Jordan Z the Tennessee
company that sells those little blank
discs for the mid to turn into Lincoln
pennies so they're in the pocket of big
zinc and if not for the penny what are
they supposed to do with all those blank
zinc disks hold a mini Olympic discus
throwing competition starring hamsters
from around the globe
yes that's clearly exactly what they
should do but even that zinc company
doesn't seem to care that much about
pennies so far this year they've only
spent around one hundred and forty
thousand dollars lobbying on it which
isn't much considering that jardín
corporation their parent company is a 10
billion dollar business the penny
contract is nothing to them next to the
money that they make from products like
and this is true Yankee Candle crockpots
and class rings essentially jars and
makes anything that you would find left
behind after a burglary but
but there is there's actually one more
staunch defender of the penny Lincoln
enthusiasts the Lincoln library told us
they'll fight for the Lincoln penny
right down to the last cent yep but why
Lincoln doesn't need the penny for
notoriety he's everywhere
we've put him on novelty bandages cup
and ball games and creepy cheer pets and
you know what else we put in the $5 bill
you know the thing that's worth 500
times more than the penny and if you
think you will maybe we could make the
penny out of something cheaper we can't
the US Mint admitted that there are no
alternative metal compositions that
reduce the manufacturing cost of the
penny below its face value essentially
there is no cheaper way to make a penny
because there is no other substance that
is so worthless without making them out
of DVDs of The Cosby Show and we don't
want it we don't want to do that you
don't want to do that and if we wanted
to get rid of the penny we could do it
Canada Australia Ireland New Zealand and
many others have all done so in recent
years it wouldn't even be the first time
the u.s. got rid of a coin we used to
have a half penny and guess when we got
rid of it the half penny was dropped in
1857 because inflation had rendered its
buying power absolute they knew it
didn't make sense to keep a currency
that had no value and that was back in
1857 when people were scared of the moon
and wipe their asses with rocks
so come on let's dump the penny not
because we need to not because it will
change a great deal but because there
are certain things we know are
impossible to get rid of terrorism
herpes and Guy Fieri but but the penny
is a nuisance we could actually do
something about so let's do it America
let's get the penny out of our pockets
out of our dogs out of our fridges and
out of our asses we can do this
you